let's go next to our caller from the
five
four zero area code who's calling today
from five four
zero
five four zero please unmute if you have
us muted
there you go yes who's this hey david
how's it going uh mitch from virginia
here
hey mitch um i was just calling in
because i had watched some of your
segments on
voting for jobiden over donald trump
and myself i'm kind of undecided at this
point
uh i am not sure whether i'm not gonna
vote or whether i'm not gonna vote for
joe blyden or whether i'll end up
pulling the lever form um
but i watched some of your segments and
to me it kind of feels like
um for you you're you're pulling the
lever
against trump um and
for me i want to be more convinced by
biden
okay so let me just pause there because
i want to clarify my position
me voting for joe biden is not
exclusively me
voting against trump there are two
people who might be the next president
and i'm choosing the better option so
you know
to to characterize it as it's only a
vote
against trump or it's a lesser of two
evils
it's i don't want to put any of that
sort of
frosting on the cake so to speak it's
here are the two choices
and it's so abundantly obvious which is
the better choice that i'm
very clear that i'm going to vote for
the better choice does that make sense
yeah yeah i apologize i mean you get
your position wrong no problem
um yeah so i mean i think
you might benefit a little bit from
maybe
um just talking more about
what those things about buying that you
like i know like
general overview and i mean it's
it's very clear that they have very
different positions right but right
maybe just talking about specific
policies might
help you i don't know if the goal of
your segments is to just state your
position or to convince others
no this is a very good question i'm not
trying to convince
anyone and i'm not certainly i
i've not been shaming people who don't
plan to vote for joe biden
would i am if i'm evangelizing for
anything i'm evangelizing for everybody
to be honest
about why they are taking the action
they plan to take so
there are some people on the left who
are kind of playing coy
where they don't like trump but they
really only focus
at least publicly on criticizing biden
and they won't actually say they'd
rather trump to biden but it's like
ultimately that's what it comes down to
so if someone says listen you know what
i was a bernie person
the reason i'm not voting for joe biden
is because given these two choices
i actually believe to hell with it let
trump
get another four years now they might
say that because they want to punish the
dnc
they might say it because maybe they
genuinely agree with trump more on
policy but
what i don't want is people kind of
playing coy and playing this game
where they're like yeah yeah trump is
bad but like joe biden
in 94 didn't take social security cuts
off the table
it's like okay but hold on he's clearly
not running on that now that was 26
years ago
do you prefer trump or biden now if
people come away
and they're like i prefer trump i just
i'd rather trump be president for the
next four years
beautiful we're now clear on where you
stand but it's the playing coy
about biden being bad but it's like okay
so
would you prefer trump listen i'm just
pointing out that the dnc
screwed bernie okay do you prefer trump
let's just be honest about why people
are making their voting decisions that's
all i want
vote however you want yeah
yeah um so i mean i haven't
seen personally like a whole lot of that
i mean i guess you're saying like
they're just pivoting
right they're not saying which they
prefer
they're not being upfront they're not
being upfront
sometimes about who they actually prefer
and they're not being upfront about
their motives
for focusing their criticism on biden
and and if they were transparent they're
like listen
i think biden as a center-left candidate
is going to make us worse off in the
long run which is why
i'd rather it be trump if it's not going
to be bernie
that's a position we can now actually
talk about like adults
but if we don't really understand what
the goal
is of someone just saying oh biden this
biden that well
then we can't even really talk about it
okay yeah yeah i definitely appreciate
your coverage on all of this you've
you've been upfront and honest so and
definitely
everything that's going on now is
definitely weighing heavily on me
um with the whole protests and
trump's reaction to it it's really
weighing heavily on
that's interesting so like at some point
did you consider yourself
a never biden guy
um no i don't think i had ever
considered myself a never biden guy
okay a skeptical never hillary person in
2016. i i
just felt very strongly and i was a lot
younger at that point
and newer to politics but i just
consider
i just consider that i want to vote for
someone and not against someone
and biden's policies are lackluster to
me
i mean not to everybody but to me so is
there a particular biden policy that you
really dislike
um yeah he's not for medicare for all so
that's
huge right right right and so
is in your paradigm so bernie wants
medicare for all
trump wants this crazy thing worth 24
million
people will lose coverage biden is into
the idea of
public option plus um expanding he said
he likes the idea of expanding medicare
to 60 plus plus larger subsidies
to people above and beyond the subsidies
we have now so
it might give health care to you know
some tens of millions of additional
people
does the fact that biden's position is
so much better than trump's
way on you at all or does it only matter
that biden's position is not bernie's
no it matters to me that even though
biden's position is better than trump's
and is
good it is undeniably good right
it is a positive thing to give health
care to more people
it weighs on me more that
his plan leaves three million more
uninsured so
i feel like we should push for medicare
for all because
wait hold on how does bio you're saying
how does biden's plan
in the net leave three million more
people uninsured that's
you just agreed that that's not the case
no no no not more than current
three million people total will not be
covered by biden's plan so
okay i got it i got you okay third he
would
only insure 10 of those 13.
okay but so then that's making you think
you might vote for the guy who will take
it away from 24 million more people
absolutely not okay all right good good
good good
okay all right very good my friend i
appreciate the phone call thank you so
much that is all the time i have for
today i apologize i was not able to get
to everybody
i will take calls again believe you me